el descontento entre los trabajadores
continúa en Francia Este martes miles
salieron a las calles para manifestarse
con una demanda concreta el aumento de
los salarios
estamos aquí para exigir mayores
salarios mejores condiciones de trabajo
la jubilación a los 60 años y luego para
denunciar los ataques al derecho de
huelga y al trabajo sindical así como la
obstrucción a la libertad de pensamiento
de los trabajadores
Y es que la inflación ha disparado los
precios en el país y ha reducido
drásticamente el poder adquisitivo de
los franceses algo que ha indignado a
muchos ciudadanos que acusan al gobierno
de Manuel macón de no querer dialogar ni
atender las demandas de los trabajadores
una tensión que llevó a enfrentamientos
entre la policía y los manifestantes en
París
es un ataque al derecho de huelga lo
reafirmó cuando la policía va a recoger
a los huelguistas a sus casas y los
obliga a ir a trabajar es un ataque al
derecho ya que escucho a muchos
ministros que dicen apenas hay 100
huelguistas en refinerías Bueno cuando
solo hay 100 huelguistas hay que buscar
no huelguistas para hacer el trabajo
entonces es mentira esta huelga es
popular
ciudades comunantes dunkerque o Marsella
también salieron a protestar uniéndose a
la huelga de los trabajadores de la
refinería y centrales nucleares que ha
generado problemas de abastecimiento una
cuarta parte de las gasolineras del país
sufren escasez y solo 30 de los 56
reactores nucleares están en
funcionamiento lejos de detenerse se
espera que otros sectores como la salud
y la alimentación se sumen a las
protestas una encuesta del grupo El ave
muestra que uno de cada tres franceses
estaría dispuesto a manifestarse en las
próximas semanas